Secret Invasion now streaming only on DisneyPlus
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Marvel
just dropped a brand new secret Invasion Episode
2 trailer video there was also some footage from
further episodes beyond 2 so I'll try to point
that out when we get to it I'm doing videos for
all the episodes just like the other Marvel
Disney plus series and we're doing a giveaway
for Disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite Easter egg so far in the series just
starting at the beginning of the trailer so
they start with voice over from Sonia ballsworth
Union Jack 2. if you want to think about it in
comic book terms like there's the first version
and the second version of the character to take
the name she's meant to be the daughter of the
original Union Jack character she was clowning
on Nick Fury a little bit in episode one because
they've been gone for so long she was trying to
tell him that he basically lost his Edge but
while she was doing that she was referencing
their history together working together as spies
during the Cold War era and their history in the
comics Union Jack's history with Nick Fury in the
howling Commando Comics they moved the timeline
when they started doing the MCU movies because
they didn't start till Iron Man 1 and 2 2008
so everybody was born a little bit later in the
timeline in the comics Nick Fury actually fought
in World War II with the Howling Commandos in
the original Captain America they did have a
Union Jack though in the Captain America first
avenger movie the war in the shadows that she's
talking about is what's been happening since
Avengers end game that Nick Fury has not been
around for although I think part of the idea
is that he kind of knows what's been going
on but he's mostly been on his space station so
for the most part all the different people he's
encountering even Rhody for example think that
he has absolutely no idea what's going on I'll
talk more about Roadie in a second too because
there's definitely something sus with Roadie
definitely think that he's gonna wind up being
a scroll there'll be a couple more big reveals
throughout the series about big Avengers
characters big MCU characters that have
been Scrolls for a long time Brody just happens to
be one of the biggest theories right now but the
funny thing is while he's walking through the
woods and they're having the Sonya fallsworth
voice over from a new scene you actually see them
cut a weird edit with footage of her talking in a
completely different sentence like her lip flaps
do not match the voice over the footage of her
is from conversation in episode one so it was a
completely different conversation that they were
having unless it was some sort of deleted scene
one of the weird things about Marvel trailers
is that some of them are pretty cool but usually
you could probably find a fan trailer of some fake
Marvel movie out there that's way better than
their real trailers normally you think that a
big studio with an infinite amount of money could
come up with a better version of a trailer than a
fan could I don't know why they cut the trailer
like that unless you was talking to him in some
kind of spoilery scene he's already gotten his
eye patch back so he's been to that Grave site
he's pulled all of his stuff out of his grave
part of the idea I think is that he wanted the
world to believe that he died during the final
battle in Avengers end game and he just used the
opportunity to check out that makes me wonder if
Sonia Falls where a lot of the other intelligence
communities like MI6 people around the world knew
that Talos was really pretending to be Nick Fury
and his wife was pretending to be Maria Hill
you have to imagine though the way that Talos
explained all the Skrulls and how he got kicked
off the council is that the Skrulls knew that he
was doing that which means graphic knew that he
was doing that which means Graphics group knew
that he was is doing that and because they've
been infiltrating all these other different
organizations around the world it means that the
other organizations probably found out too one of
the reasons why I think they're giving him the
eye patch back is just because it's so iconic
like it is weird seeing Nick Fury without his
eye patch on and they wanted him to feel like
he was on the outs in episode one and when he
puts the eye patch back on it's like yeah I'm
getting back in it where he basically says that
he's getting back in the saddle one of the other
interesting details is that when he's opening the
grave here of his stuff it actually looks like a
star chart so I think it's just a reference to
his history with the Skrulls speaking of which
you do kind of wonder if he's benefited from
working with the Skrulls and getting access to
their technology since the 90s one thing they
don't make very clear is that even though Nick
Fury worked with shield for a long time you have
like all these other people this big government
organization all this Government funding that
happened for years it sounds like he didn't let
the US government in on his relationship with
the Skrulls like he had this relationship with
them that was completely separate from what he
was doing with Shield otherwise you'd probably
would have seen way more Skrulls running around
back in the 90s in the early 2000s I think the
way they explained this during episode 1 is
that at least at the present day before secret
Invasion there were a limited number of Skrulls
running around on planet Earth and they knew who
all of them were until secret Invasion there's a
couple scenes from episode one everybody's still
wondering about Maria Hill it is possible that her
death is a fake out like there's life model Decoy
for talking about Agents of Shield references with
Coulson faking out his death although technically
he did die and then come back to life by the
very end of this series they did do a big Kong
book Easter egg he did become a life model decoy
version of himself sort of like a backup version
of Coulson there's also the idea that the series
is supposed to feel like it's in the same tone as
the Winter Soldier movie and during that Nick
Fury faked his death so do not be surprised if
Maria Hill winds up showing up before the end of
the series again also I think some people spotted
her on the IMDb for the Marvel's movie so it is
possible she always comes back in Future Marvel
projects I think the way they ended episode 1 with
her just bleeding out there in the square and the
camera panning out slowly they wanted to show you
the body like Oh see it's a body in a comic book
movie if you don't see the body that means that
they're still alive so we're going to show you the
body so you definitely think that she's dead but
it's only episode one so we'll see if they truly
did wind up Ned starking her everybody feeling
bad for her and Sith now like characters that
used to be super popular that everybody's excited
to see come back and then they just quickly kill
off without any big ceremony just remember what
happened with Coulson just remember what happened
with Nick Fury's death fake out then you see Sonia
Falls were talking to Nick Fury at his gravesite
fake gravesite we should say and because of the
events of episode 1 we could say this scene here
is confirmation that Gaia is finding graphic
who's replaced hundreds and hundreds of people
like there's a giant Warehouse of what looked
like really powerful important figures around
the world that they replaced Sonia fallsworth's
voiceover says it's a ticking Time Bomb kind of
situation this guy is freaking out they just plays
into the whole idea of them stealing bombs and
trying to create this mutually assured destruction
scenario this war between Russia the United States
they're also trying to do that with the rest of
the world Nations too eventually that's the idea
like Russia and the United States would fire
their nukes at each other and it would trigger
this chain reaction that would basically destroy
pretty much all the humans on the planet allowing
the Skrulls to sort of fly in and just move in
in the ashes it'd be kind of like a version of
Avengers Infinity war with a snap and what
happened during the blip that five-year time
Jump with a bunch of people just moving in to old
people's houses they had a joke about that during
Spider-Man far from home Aunt May got blipped
back after Avengers endgame after the Hulk snap
in their apartment from Captain America Civil War
but in the five-year time Jump another family had
just moved in because nobody was living there so
you have to imagine all the Skrulls just hoping
that the humans killed each other off they're just
gonna move into everybody else's places when Gaia
tells Nick Fury It's You Who lit the match that's
just a reference to that 30-year plan the promise
that Nick Fury and Captain Marvel made to the
Skrulls about finding them a new home a lot of
people have problems with this and you're not
totally wrong like what was going on in the 90s
and the early 2000s that Nick Fury couldn't go
find them in other planet it's a very a very big
universe for those of you wondering how they were
going to do that without a bunch of spaceships the
idea is that they had Marvel's original spaceship
at the end of the first Captain Marvel movie they
were going to use that to take the Skrulls to
a new planet eventually hopefully during one of
the future episodes they'll explain what happened
during the early 2000s that prevented that if it
had been later in the timeline you could make the
excuse that the events of the first Avengers movie
second Avengers movie Avengers Infinity War were
happening but before that they don't have a lot
of excuses this scene seems like Graphics group of
Skrulls stealing another device not sure what's in
the case make all the Pulp Fiction jokes that you
want show me what's in the case because it's being
chilled it could either be a biological agent or
just part of the device that they're creating here
in this abandoned power plant a little more
footage from the end of episode one with the
explosion and that Russian celebration this scene
looks like Nick Fury walking into one of those old
abandoned power plants the architecture seems
similar to the power plant that they were in in
episode one because graphic pretended to be Nick
Fury and kill Maria Hill in episode one it seems
like that will continue like he'll continue to
pretend to be Nick Fury because it looks like he's
firing on the U.S president's Convoy here that's
probably why in the other trailers you see the U.S
agents pulling their guns on Nick Fury because
they think that he tried to kill the president
even though it was technically graphic pretending
to be him this is another scene of graphic looking
at some device that they're creating in that
abandoned power plant base this scene is of
Olivia Coleman and Sonia fallsworth getting
ready to interrogate what seems like a Skrull
pretending to be a human and she looks like she's
going full vowel on her like really evil Sinister
looking even though she's technically meant to
be on the good side they want to make her seem
like a darker edgier vowel type of character who
will do anything to protect the UK during episode
1 Talos talked about trying to prevent them
from killing a bunch of Skrulls because Sonya
fallsworth was going to use this excuse to kill
pretty much all the Skrulls that they came across
on planet Earth even the ones who weren't part of
Graphics group just like the normal ones trying to
live their lives peacefully then there's a scene
of roadie in the president's convoy and is part
of that big scene where you see a version of Nick
Fury really it's like a Skrull potato Nick Fury
firing on the president's Convoy and it seems
like Rhodey is in that Convoy well that happens
one of the reasons why he might subject himself
to something like that he could be writing in a
completely different car or it could be because
Skrulls bodies are so much more resilient than
humans he could soak the damage from a blast like
that so it just seems like more evidence that he
will wind up being a Skrull a lot of people also
wondering why he wasn't limping in episode one too
because he does wear that special device you
saw in Avengers end game in The Avengers new
base he does have special Stark Tech that helps
him walk a little more normally without needing
a bunch of tech but I think part of the idea is
they want you to question everyone's identity if
they're acting very differently than they were
in previous movies like Roadie seems kind of
weird he wasn't acting this way during Avengers
end game or even all the Marvel movies before
Thanos showed up in Avengers Infinity War then
the end with a couple new scenes of Nick Fury
just staring at camera with his traditional eye
patch on like I'm back if you spotted any other
Easter eggs or references in the trailer footage
that he didn't talk about in the video Just Right
them Below in the comments my full episode 2 video
will post next week after they release it remember
there's six episodes total so I think within the
next couple of episodes we will find out about a
couple of MCU characters that have been Skrulls
this whole time but I am expecting them to hold
a couple of a big reveal like big Skrull reveals
till the final episode it definitely seems like
they're gonna try and kill off the US president
everyone posts all your theories in the comments
below and I'll name a new giveaway winner in
my next big Marvel video everyone click here
for my full secret Invasion Episode 1 video and
click here for my brand new Spider-Man 4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!